the Joe Rogan experience I use one of
your expressions all the time the touch
of death and there is no better example
than what we saw Saturday night with
Deontay Wilder Jesus Christ can that guy
punch
I had him losing all their own yeah me
too and I thought one round was really
close could it go either way but I had
it six to none
and that right hand my god it's so crazy
it doesn't even make sense when you look
at that shot it landed it above like
kind of like in the forehead this area
not only not even on the chin no you
usually hear if you're a powerful
puncher you could days a guy yeah put
him out the way he did yeah Wow and no
one's up to knowing that just right from
here but that's touch of death crazy
like nobody ever think about that guy's
record 41 knockouts one decision one
draw it's incredible
undefeated 41 knockouts in 42 fights I
mean that is bonkers and he was getting
outbox like he's not the best boxer when
I doesn't care to Bach yeah yeah that's
just he knows yeah yeah like it's such a
crazy strategy because out of anyone
that has ever fought in the heavyweight
division he is the one guy that
literally can shut everyone's lights out
with one shot everyone's a knockout
artist Foreman was a knockout artist
Frazier Tyson of course was a knockout
artist but not like this guy this guy's
got it's like another level of craziness
I would agree I mean he knows himself
that's what's so beautiful mmm-hmm if he
was less strategic he would have started
fighting really early I mean yeah maybe
he zapped that power he has but he knows
he knows exactly didn't care he lost six
rounds ya know he had no qualms about it
and he got hurt just before just before
he knocked out Lewis he was hurt and he
stayed calm he's like oh now you're
gonna come for it now you're gonna walk
into the right and bang yeah it's
incredible well I think he also knew
that from the first fight Ortiz started
to fade and the first fight was very
similar in that the first few rounds
there was very little action and then it
started to pick up and then Ortiz
started to fade but Artie's put it on
him in that first fight if you watched
that first fight you're like wow this is
a crazy rematch for him to take but in
this fight he just fought up
perfect strategy just waiting and people
oh my god I was on Twitter of reading
people this guy can't even box like did
you not see what happened you say camp
box he's undefeated he's the [ __ ]
heavyweight champion of the world he has
he tied Muhammad Ali for the most title
defenses ever did you really just say he
can't box in fact he's a professional
boxer go in there with him then go in
the if I laced you up we've read before
that you would be like will you be so
petrified you would turn white and faint
the way he punches is so strange it's so
strange and you know when he fought
Tyson Fury he told me weigh 209 pounds
oh really
209 that's it that's it Wow Oh crazy Wow
it's a phenom like all humans are not
created equal some people just have a
beautiful hand of cards yes that guy's
got four aces and he puts them right in
your face boom he understands what he's
good at
mm-hmm and he fights that way yeah just
brilliant yes I always tell my students
it's fighting these two things
it's one is level you got to get to a
certain level and then the second thing
you have to figure out your style like
you have to know everything about what
you do like for instance if you look at
Ali and Tyson they fought totally
differently to equally in my opinion
like okay we could split hairs and say
who was better let's say they fought it
would be very competitive whoever you
think would win in that fight it would
be very competitive
Ali fights the total opposite of Tyson
Ali's circles supposedly the wrong way
if you look at the book of boxing they
tell you don't circle towards the power
side he doesn't care and his style it
makes sense he's up on his toes he's
jabbing he barely ever throws a body
shot he throws he's thrown a handful of
body shots in his entire career whereas
Tyson is the total opposite he marches
forward he has that peekaboo style he
has that you know he's got the gloves
tied up to his chin and a totally
different style if Tyson tried to fight
like Ali he would lose you know but
they're at the same level but they
figured out hey what am I good at what
what advantages do I have physically
what disadvantages do I have physically
and that's why at one point you have to
figure out your style and I feel that's
where most fighters fall apart they
never figure out their style they're
trying to do with some trainer told them
they're trying to do with the guy they
the most
and the ring does they never find out
exactly how they what's best for them
mmm that's such a good point because
it's such a creative art form in that
way and I do believe that martial arts
are an art form I really do because to
me it's so beautiful like even that
right hand that Deonte landed that to me
was gorgeous there's never been a
prettier sunset or a more beautiful
mountain just black what's that's spray
that's the the way you see the spray the
sweat come off his head and then Ortiz
crumbles and Deonte walks away like this
chest up like [ __ ] are you not
getting up
he knew he was knew he knew he knew when
he dropped them he walked off right away
like he knew he was calling the way he
walked off - yeah it's like he knows you
know god damn that guy's got crazy power
but that but what you said is so
important because it's a creative
endeavor you're trying to figure out how
to land shots and you're also trying to
disguise what your ideas are what your
tactics are and you've got to figure out
what works best for your body type and
that's so open-ended like martial arts
are so it's so open-ended
once the referee says fight there's all
this creativity involved and that's
something that I think a lot of people
don't really appreciate 100% sometimes
you have a trainer who kill that
creativity because he tells you look
this is how you fight right and if you
go outside of that mold no no you're
reprimanded yeah so me me if a fighter
wants to drop his head should you drop
your hands and a fighter should you hold
them up well it depends what kind of guy
you are
if you got incredible eyes and you see
shots coming from a mile away and you're
you you're successful with your hands
down or one hand down per se let's say
then keep doing it but you gotta that's
why I think sparring is so important
because gonna be spar we actually try it
now we're testing we're testing hey does
this airplane fly or is it gonna crash
and burn well we better test it in the
gym before we take it out in the arena
and find out it doesn't fly and I always
thought guys look if you have if you're
fighting with your hands down show me in
practice that you're successful then I
won't I won't say anything negative I
won't say I won't change your style I'll
let it be but first we have to see that
you're successful because theories is
one thing but then when you get in there
and try this a whole other
[Applause]